once they have that they have everything
they have
total access to your payment card and
can make purchases either online
or in person and it could be depending
on how much you check your account
days weeks or months until you realize
it
thieves stealing your bank information
with just one swipe
it is a growing problem across our
valley with police recovering dozens of
devices
doing just that over the past few months
investigators telling our i-team the
surge of people getting unemployment is
luring these criminals in right now the
i-team's david charn shows us how
they're doing it
and how to keep your money safe
it was smaller amounts and it was just
like
wait a minute that minute for erin kelly
turned
into one valuable piece of time at one
of the atms
i probably was skimmed it's when he
realized his bank of america account the
one with his deter unemployment benefits
was slowly getting drained several
hundred dollars
gone with one swipe now we see an
increase of people needing to withdraw
money
weekly sergeant eric burkett with metro
police says
thieves are taking advantage of people
in similar situations
they want your account number and they
want your pin code because once they
have that
they have everything this is all real
stuff this is all real
devices that have been located in the
las vegas valley within the last six
months
parquet showed the i-team what these
criminals are building home signs
projects
scanning and stealing the bank info
hidden on your card's magnetic strip
low-grade tech glued on or stuffed into
the real devices
we're so used to touch it pull on it
twist it if it comes apart it's probably
wrong
it's also these point of sale machines
it looks like the real thing
but the one you're looking at is fake
there's even
tiny cameras aimed at a keypad waiting
to catch your fingers
in your pin we're looking at intelligent
thieves i mean
you have to have some type of knowledge
of engineering you have to have some
type of knowledge of machinery to make
these
implement these but not intelligent
enough to hide
investigators say surveillance from a
bank in green valley caught a car with
this man inside
police say 20-year-old marion panaru is
behind more than a dozen skimming
devices across the valley
recording nearly 600 deter account
numbers
investigators say the romanian national
took the stolen account info
and re-encoded ordinary gift cards with
the data
and a lot of those forged cards
contained unemployment benefit cards
and other people's bank account
information that we're going to be used
by the suspects to withdraw
cash and continue to victimize those
consumers of the atm kelly got his money
back
but says the thieves stole a little part
of human decency
and nobody likes to be stolen from and
when it's something that in a in a time
where it's desperate for you
that that happened it's even a little
more disheartening
police tell the i-team banks do a pretty
good job at making sure there aren't any
skimming devices on their atms but they
still say the best thing you can do to
protect yourself is to try to pay with
your phone if you can tap
it or also if you can tap to pay with
your card
if that option is available i'm david
charns 8 news now
all right so listen to this the i-team
also found out where the skimmers were
found
according to his arrest report police
found skimming devices involving the
suspect david just told us about
at two bank of america atms in the
southeast valley you can see
both of those locations there on this
map one near nellis and boulder highway
and another at sunset and green valley
parkway
police say there's really nothing banks
or deter can do once they issue a card
since it's not an issue with the card
and measures are already in place to
keep you safe
the i-team reached out to bank of
america and did not receive a response